SOWMYA KANNAN: Hello.
I'm Sowmya Kannan.
Today I'll be giving you an
overview of the Associate Cloud
engineer track that is
part of a Career Readiness
Program from Google Cloud.
In today's presentation, we'll
start with an introduction
to Google and Google Cloud.
We'll see why businesses
are moving to Google Cloud
Platform.
I'll briefly discuss the
increasing skills gap
in the "cloud-first" world and
how you can help your students
build career skills
by leveraging Google
Cloud's Associate
Cloud engineer track.
I'll provide an overview
and review the benefits
of this program and timelines.
I'll also share what
your responsibilities
would be as a faculty leader.
I'll discuss how
Google Cloud will
assist faculty and students
in completing this program.
Coursera and Qwiklabs setup
will be presented next,
and I'll conclude with the
next steps for you to take.
I'm sure most of you are
aware that Google started
in 1998 in a small garage.
Today, Google has more than 70
offices across 50 countries.
For the past 20 years,
Google has been working hard
to organize the
world's information
and make it universally
accessible and useful.
We've created products such as
search, Android, Chrome, Maps,
Play, YouTube, Gmail
and Drive, all now
with over a billion users.
However, it's not
just the scale that's
interesting about
these products.
What's interesting is
the infrastructure,
Google's core technology
infrastructure
that we had to build in
order to achieve our mission.
This infrastructure
powers all our products.
Google Cloud Platform is a suite
of cloud computing services
that runs on the same
infrastructure used
by Google internally for
its end user products.
So why are businesses moving
to Google Cloud Platform?
When making this
transition, most companies
are not just looking at how
they can move their existing
computing to the cloud, or
to reduce costs, and increase
reliability and security.
They are also hoping to
create new opportunities.
Google Cloud has been placed
in the leaders quadrant
by Gartner in 2018.
Forester also recognizes
Google as a leader in key areas
of cloud computing.
More than $1.3
trillion in IT spending
will be directly or indirectly
affected by the shift
to cloud by 2022.
Adoption of cloud
native applications
will double by 2020.
This accelerated
move towards cloud
has created a tremendous demand
for qualified professionals
who are proficient in
cloud technologies.
The growth in cloud
adoption has resulted
in a corresponding increase
in the need for workers
skilled in cloud technologies.
So are your students
cloud ready?
To bridge the skills gap,
we've built an enterprise
ready curriculum leading
up to industry recognized
certification.
Lead a sprint through the
Associate Cloud engineer
track to empower your
students to succeed
in cloud-related careers.